the Resident Evil games are all about  shooting zombies and creepy locations  with all of that blood and guts on the  walls you're gonna work up an appetite  what just me well I'm Tony and this is  your very delicious gamespot news update  capcom has launched its new cooking with  capcom video series and for the first  episode they teamed up with cantina  carnitas for a resident evil themed  burrito what goes into it well you start  with two tortillas then add red pepper  rice red herbs pork cheese black beans  salsa sour cream green herbs and a  little bit of that classic t-virus and  by t-virus they mean a super secret hot  sauce anybody else hungry as host Neil  Gorton points out this is the first and  possibly last episode of cooking with  Capcom but there is certainly other  recipes the developer could cover  phoenix wright ramen megaman muffins  street fighter tara misu who knows for  now you can stick with gamespot for a  burritos worth of video game news and  reviews  you